[Music]
hey you guys book review time once again
we have a classic for you today i
actually this was actually not the book
that i was going to do this week but it
so happened that the one that i started
to do
or the one that i started to read for
the review was going to be way too long
and i wasn't going to have a chance to
finish it by the time that this needs to
be recorded
so basically i just took a much shorter
book and one that i had read
before uh you know even though it's been
quite a while since i've read it
and i said okay well i can knock this
out like in a few hours and uh
read it and i'm already kind of familiar
with the story so i decided that i was
going to do that just so i'd have some
content to put up
so today we're talking about richard
matheson's
1958 a stir of
echoes now obviously if you look at this
paper back here it just says stir of
echoes on the front that is because
this uh you know edition of the book was
put out to coincide with the
1999 kevin bacon film uh which was just
called stir of echoes but the book is
actually called a stir of echoes
not that it makes a huge amount of
difference but you know so as i
mentioned
this book came out in 1958 now the
interesting thing about this
i had read a lot of richard matheson
stuff
prior to reading this book and prior to
seeing the movie probably i mean i had
read duel i've read a lot of his short
stories i've read i am legend
um hell house uh probably one of my
favorite books of all time also a great
film
uh so what ended up happening with this
was that when i saw ster of echoes
the movie in 1999 which i saw in the
theater
i was aware that it was based on a
richard matheson novel but i hadn't read
it at that
point so actually you know after i saw
the movie i went and like picked up the
book and read it
now the interesting thing about this and
i will probably talk a little bit about
the movie too even though
we have done a movie retrospective on it
it was a while back that we did it
because stir of echoes i feel like i try
to like push it on horror fans like at
every opportunity because
i feel like it was a movie that kind of
got
swept under the rug or kind of flew
under the radar like it did pretty well
like when it came out in the theater but
um i feel like you know that was the
same year that uh
you know the sixth sense came out that
was the same year that the blair witch
project came out
so i kind of feel like it sort of got
lost in the shuffle
and uh it's a really really really good
movie and the first time i saw it like
in the theater i saw it and it was
really late at night when i was walking
out to the parking lot of the movie
theater it like really really creeped me
out it's really well done
but i will say that if you've seen the
movie which like i said you should
because it's excellent
don't worry about it spoiling the book
for you
or if you've read the book don't worry
about oh i already know what's going to
happen in the movie because the movie
and the book
are pretty much completely different not
in the sense that it's in an
in name only adaptation i'm not saying
that the basic bones of the story are
the same
but the outcome of the mystery um kind
of the focus
of the story is different so i'll
probably like talk about that a little
bit just because i thought it was an
interesting
comparison to make but um you know but
you can go back and watch our movie
retrospective about stir of echoes if
you just want something about the movie
because i'm going to talk about the book
mostly
but i'll kind of talk about where it
deviated from the movie as well because
i thought that was interesting
so the book is basically okay so there's
a guy named tom
wallace and him and his wife ann
and their toddler son richard i don't
think they ever say how old richard is
but he's old enough to kind of play out
in the sandbox on his own so i'm
assuming he's like
three so they live in sort of this
you know very 50s era suburb
in california i think it's a suburb of
la if i'm
you know remembering it correctly it's
not hugely important it could be just
like a suburb anywhere
usa whatever so they're kind of like a
very 50s middle class
type of family like he works at a plant
but he kind of has like a
you know an upper little level office
job you know she's a stay-at-home mom
they have one toddler and she is
also pregnant with their second child
now what ends up happening so they know
all their neighbors and it's just kind
of like this very closed and it's you
know it's one of those kind of 50s
hey let's go next door and you know play
bridge with the neighbors or like you
know borrow their newspaper
or whatever it's just that kind of stuff
so what ends up happening
at the beginning of the book and this is
told from tom wallace's
perspective it's in the first person he
goes over they all go over to this uh
you know like a little dinner party uh
that's being held by
their neighbors um elsie and ron
now elsie no one really likes elsie
she's kind of portrayed as being sort of
this
attention she's a little bit like of an
attention [ __ ] kinda like she's one of
those
oh i think i'm way hotter than i am and
she's like super flirtatious and that
kind of thing so a lot of people find
her sort of tiresome i guess
but you know it's the neighborhood you
know you have to kind of hang out with
the neighbors that's just what you did
back then so
they go to this uh this party at this
house now
while they're there it so happens that
anne's brother
phil so tom's brother-in-law is visiting
now he's in his
early 20s he's 20 or 21 and he is a
psychology major at uc berkeley and he's
really really interested in hypnosis
so at the party uh you know after
everybody's kind of had dinner and
they're just kind of hanging out he's
like you know i've
you know i've done hypnosis and i got
people to do this that and the other
thing
so there's like this big folder roll
about who's gonna
let phil hypnotize them and obviously
nobody really wants to because they're
like you know you're gonna
it's either not gonna work or you're
gonna make me do stupid [ __ ] and
everyone's gonna laugh at me and nobody
really does that so
kind of by process of elimination tom
uh ends up getting hypnotized by his
brother-in-law and it takes kind of a
while because he's like he doesn't buy
it he doesn't think it's gonna work or
anything like that you know for a few
pages it's just kind of like
busting each other's balls about it so
even though tom thinks that the hypnosis
is not gonna work on him boy
does it actually work
what ends up happening and this is very
similar to what happens in the movie
although in the movie uh kevin bacon's
character whose name is also tom
although his last name is witsky rather
than wallace
um he gets uh hypnotized by his
sister-in-law but you know it's
essentially kind of the same and she's
kind of like a flaky new agey kind of
person whereas
uh the dude phil in this is kind of more
like a
a hypnotist because i guess like back
back in 1958 when this was written
that was considered more scientific i
guess or it wasn't like seen as like
new agey or paranormal or anything
because it you know it was kind of like
a legitimate
thing that they did in psychology um
rather than kind of like more of a
magician trick which i guess would be
more
i know they do hypnosis and stuff like
that nowadays but i'm just saying that
back then it was seen as more
maybe more have had a kind of a veneer
of scientific respectability perhaps
so yeah what ends up happening is that
so while tom was hypnotized
he finds out later from you know
everyone else at the party including his
wife
that he came up with he dredged up like
all these memories from his childhood
that he had forgotten all about and like
people that he went to school with that
he had forgotten about
and all this other kind of stuff but and
at first it seems kind of like huh
that's interesting and you know he does
crazy [ __ ] like
you know later on i guess phil gave him
like a post-hypnotic suggestion to like
take his left shoe off and put it in the
refrigerator so he does it without
really thinking about why it's weird
and then everybody laughs at him because
they knew that that's what was going to
happen
so at first he kind of thinks it's a
lark however after the party is over
and him and his wife go back home that
night
he basically wakes up in the middle of
the night and
the way the description of it is like
really really good so he feels like just
everything in his brain is just
completely
lit up and like turned on and he feels
like
he can feel like all of these like
thoughts and emotions and stuff like
that just coming at him from all these
different directions and so he can't
sleep because his brain is just like
super active
so he goes out of the living room of the
house where he proceeds to see
a ghost or what he first uh believes to
be a ghost now he doesn't know who it is
it's just this woman that's like in a
black dress and she's looking at him
very sadly
like she wants something and he like
basically loses his [ __ ] so from then on
it comes to pass that what has happened
is that when
phil hypnotized tom he
broke open something in his brain um
there is some implication
that uh psychic ability or being a
medium or telepathy or something like
that like sort of ran
in tom's family he didn't really know
much about it but he kind of finds out a
little bit it's mentioned a couple times
later on that his grandfather was a
medium and all these other kind of stuff
so they're implying that he had always
had this latent ability in there it was
just this being
hypnotized and having these particular
suggestions
sort of opened him up so now he is
essentially
feeling the emotions and kind of hearing
snippets of the thoughts
of everybody around him his wife his
neighbors
and everything now if you think about
this and this is
actually really really well described in
the book if you think about this it
would actually probably be really
horrifying
because he is a very like tom is a very
down to earth
very every man type of character and um
he doesn't really believe in this kind
of thing obviously
so the fact that he has now become
like a conduit for all of these people's
emotions like he just meets somebody or
he
you know it passes the neighbor in the
street and he just you know feels all
this you know
hatred or angst or whatever whatever it
is that they're going through
this is actually a very torturous
experience for him and as i said that's
actually one of the most interesting
things about the book because it's in
the first person
tom is writing about just how terrible
an experience this is because
he just can't turn it off he can't
control it and it's just
you know 24 7 he's just being assaulted
by other people's
emotions and snippets of thoughts and he
doesn't really know
like he can feel people's emotions or
kind of hear their thoughts or whatever
but he doesn't really know
what it's about or who it's directed at
or anything like that it's just all
impressionistic so it starts to kind of
i don't want to say it starts driving
crazy but it is
like kind of torturing him and his
health starts to suffer
and also his marriage starts to suffer
because his poor wife
anne who is pregnant you know she
doesn't really understand it at first
and he tries to keep a lot of things
from her because he doesn't want to
upset her
because some of the things that he sees
are very upsetting
but obviously because it's taking such a
physical and mental toll on him
she does notice there's something that
matters so for a long time she just kind
of thinks he's cracking up or he's just
like
going nuts or whatever tries to get him
to go to the doctor he doesn't really
want to go
but then as it goes on and his uh
visions and premonitions
he starts to like know what's happening
for example at one point
him and his wife they you know go out to
dinner and they leave their
son with a babysitter and no sooner have
they gotten to the restaurant that tom
has a very very horrible feeling of
dread that something is the matter
and they really really need to get back
home and anna's just really pissed off
about this
but it turns out when they you know tear
ass back home
the babysitter is trying to kidnap their
son like they find her down the street
or whatever
so you know and he sees little things
and big things like he kind of sees
uh what he's at work one day and he
starts feeling this horrible horrible
pain in his head
and he knows that something is wrong
with his wife and so he calls the house
and it turns out that
she was in the kitchen and like a big
can of tomatoes or something like that
like fell on her head and like sort of
knocked her out for a minute
you know so he knows little things like
that is going on
another thing too is that he starts to
understand or he starts to know what's
going on
with the neighbors like elsie the woman
who had the party at the beginning where
he was um
you know where he was hypnotized he
starts feeling like she'd always like i
said she's always been real flirty and a
lot of people
like kind of didn't really like her you
know didn't really put up with her that
much but
now that he can sort of see inside her
mind to a small extent he can see like
what a kind of a horrible like grasping
person she is and it's like really
and so he doesn't even like to be around
her anymore because just the impressions
he gets of what it's like to be inside
her mind are just so um
horrifying to him and he also starts to
feel like all the anguish of all the
other
couples in the area now if you've seen
the movie from 1999
the main thrust of the movie even though
the like i said the bones of the story
are the same
um you know kevin bacon's character tom
he also gets hypnotized by a relative
and you know which opens him up to all
these kind of psychic impressions
but the movie is a lot more focused on
the murder mystery um because that's
what that's what the movie is that's
what this is too
but the book is much more even though
the book is actually quite short it's
only about 220 pages like you can
seriously read it in one sitting and
it's a
quick read too because like a lot of
richard matheson's other stuff
his writing is just very i don't want to
say terse but it's just kind of there's
just no filler on it it's not real
florid
it's very um straightforward to the
point
he doesn't really dick around you know
what i mean he just kind of goes goes go
so it's
so the book is like a really easy read
it's a page turner there's not a lot of
digressions or
you know extraneous [ __ ] going on he
just kind of gets right down to the
point gets right to it so the
interesting thing is that the movie is
is just almost laser focused on
this murder mystery where you know tom
sees a ghost in the house which he does
in the book as well
and starts to look into the mystery of
who this girl is
um you know and who might have killed
her but the thing about it though
and a lot of the other things that he
sees in the movie
are kind of all tied in to the murder
mystery the central murder mystery
now i understand like when you're doing
a movie and like i said i love the movie
and everybody should see it
but the movie and the book are two
different things so the movie when
you're doing a movie yes you do have to
like laser focus on one thing you can't
have all these like
hanging threads or anything like hanging
out so everything that he sees
you know for example in the movie uh
there is also an event where
him and his wife go to an event like a
concert or a
sports sporting event or something like
that and they leave their kid with a
babysitter and the babysitter does
sort of try to kidnap her kidnap him or
at least they
they have that she actually kind of had
a reason for doing it and it ties in
with the greater murder mystery
in the book not so much in the book
because the point of the book
yes there is a murder mystery yes he
sees a ghost yes
it is a spirit trying to convey
information to him
but the main thrust of the book and the
main you know
the main thing that the story revolves
around is not so much that
even though that's kind of like a
through line that goes through the whole
thing
it's more about him and his
realization that this little suburban
neighborhood and all these people that
he thought he knew
had all of these horrible secrets like
all of this [ __ ] was going on behind
closed doors
and he didn't realize it but so now that
he's
has this psychic ability had has been
awakened in him
he realizes like how you know
how this like veneer of respectability
and
suburban happiness or whatever you know
the white picket fence kind of [ __ ]
how much of that is a lie because all of
the [ __ ] that's going on like at his
neighbor's houses
is horrifying now one of those things
you know that he sees does tie in with
the murder mystery and i'm not going to
spoil it because i do kind of feel like
yes the book came out in 1958 yes the
movie came out in 1999
but i feel like a lot of people haven't
seen the movie or read the book
so i don't really want to ruin the
experience for people that haven't
and as i said if you've read the book
the movie is not spoiled because
it's it's essentially it's the same
story sort of
but the resolution of the mystery is
different the murder victim is different
the motive is different everything is
different you know pretty much
other than just the barest like
generalities of the story
so keep that in mind when you're going
into the book one it's said in 1958
even though that said it's not as
set in 1958 as you might imagine
because you know if you've read some
other stuff that was written in 1958
sometimes it could seem very dated
this book not so much there are some
dated
you know kind of things in it like you
know a guy calls another guy a crumb
which no one would do nowadays that's
very 50s
um you know and there's kind of some
weird [ __ ] about what you know all the
women are housewives
you know there's also kind of a thing
where you know if you're a woman in a
[ __ ] that's like the worst thing ever
you know it's but that's real subtle
it's not like real in your face
there's also weird kind of [ __ ] about
you know somebody joking about
punching a pregnant woman in the stomach
which you know but
other than little things like that and
you know the babies that are only
charging 50 cents an hour
if you didn't know that this was written
in 1958
you might not realize that it's that old
because it just really doesn't seem
all that dated because the writing is so
modern
you know it's plotted in a very modern
sort of way
so i mean i was reading some goodreads
reviews on it and a couple of the people
said i didn't realize until
after i had read it that it was written
that long ago some people thought that
it was
written in the modern day but that it
was set back then
but no it was actually written back then
but like i said other than a few things
it doesn't really seem all that dated to
me
which is amazing considering how long
ago it was written another thing too is
that
this the book i feel like the the movie
as i said it's much more of a horror
movie in the sense of being like
just a straightforward ghost story kind
of you know i see a ghost and the ghost
wants me to do something
whereas the book is more it has that
aspect but it's more of a suspense story
it's more of a thriller
and it's more of a kind of a paranormal
it's kind of just talking about how you
would react if you if
essentially everyone's mind was suddenly
laid bare
to you and you couldn't control that you
know what i mean so you're just kind of
getting these impressions all the time
and how horrifying that would be how
that would affect your life um
you know so i don't want to like
oversell it's not
a real introverted book but it does have
that aspect to it where his character is
kind of talking about
what it feels like to have this ability
suddenly thrust upon you that you didn't
ask for
um and also you know another theme of it
i think probably the main theme
is you know how the veneer of
respectability can
hide you know this just this rot
underneath
which again it's you know nowadays it
seems like a very old hat
type of theme i suppose um you know kind
of
oh look at this perfect suburban
neighborhood and
all of these perfect people but really
you know they have all of these horrible
secrets under this you know adultery and
murder and all these other kind of
things that are going on behind closed
doors
so you know that's a very common trope
and thrillers nowadays in 1958 not so
much so this was a little bit kind of
ahead of its time i guess
and as i said the the way that it's
written makes it seem
almost like a modern story so you can
see why it was adapted
and it adapted quite well to 1999
um the in the movie they did actually
change the setting to
chicago and uh they changed the family
to a more kind of working-class family
rather than a suburban family but it
still
kind of works you know what i mean it's
the theme of it is still kind of the
same
where you know everybody has these
secrets in the neighborhood that you
people you thought you knew and stuff
like that
so it's a very it's a universal type of
theme so i think it works really well
kind of across the ages whatever decade
you set it in
which is probably why this book doesn't
really seem all that dated to me
the only criticism i can uh you know
that i can
sort of point out maybe for me is that
because the ghost story yes it is a
through line through the whole thing but
because there's so much
other stuff going on in the sense that
he's seeing things all the time that you
know he sees like for example
for another example like the night
before it happens he sees this horrible
train wreck in which like 47 people died
he has a dream about it and he wakes up
and he writes it down
and then the next day it happens and
that is probably the main thing that
finally convinces his wife that he's not
just you know going nuts or making it up
or
you know [ __ ] with her or whatever so
there's that kind of stuff but see that
doesn't have anything to do with the
central murder mystery
so there's a lot of that going on but
you know so when it gets to the very to
the end where he finally figures out hey
i'm gonna figure out what's going on
with this woman that keeps popping up in
the house because obviously
she you know she she doesn't just pop up
in the house and
so so that he sees her he also
does like some automatic writing [ __ ]
like at one point the ghost like talks
through his baby son
you know he can hear a voice through it
like so is because his son also has some
paranormal ability which they sort of uh
you know kind of apply imply a little
bit
so when it gets to the end and he's like
okay well i'm gonna figure out what this
is because obviously she's
you know been murdered or she wants me
to do something i feel like the
resolution of that was like
really quick you know what i mean
because it's because so much of the book
is spent
on other things that aren't directly
tied into the murder mystery
you know that are more tied into him
dealing with his ability and
seeing other things and his relationship
with his wife
but interestingly interestingly though
if you go back
you know because this has kind of like a
big twist ending the person that you
think
is a bad guy is not necessarily a bad
guy you know what i mean
um that's kind of all i'm going to say
about that and that's not even all that
accurate but i don't want to spoil it
too much
so it does have a big twist ending but i
do kind of feel like that if you go back
and read it a second time like if you
finish it and then go back and read it a
second time
then maybe because i think he had been
dropping hints the whole time
but i'm not real sure that he dropped
enough hints
that when you got to the end and the
twist ending came and
and the mystery was resolved i'm not
really sure if you'd be like oh i should
have seen that all along
you know what i mean so i kind of feel
like it comes a little bit out of left
field and like i said the the ending is
a little bit
abrupt i don't know it it didn't really
bother me that much
um but i can see how some other people
might be like oh okay well
that was it and then you know that it
because it just seemed like like i said
i'm not i'm not sure if it was
sufficiently set up or maybe i just
wasn't
maybe i didn't pick up all the clues
interestingly i had read this book
before
probably back when the movie came out
like so probably 1999 or 2000
and i had completely forgotten at one
how different this book was than the
movie
two i had completely forgotten the twist
ending
so so it was like a whole new book to me
because like the whole time i was
thinking it was this
that the mystery was like this one way
and then the end i was like oh my god i
totally forgot
all about that what do you know
seriously though if you are into
richard matheson at all i don't think
this is
as good a book as say hell house
or you know i am legend obviously which
is probably his
his best book or even the shrinking man
which i also i liked a lot and i think
this book has more in common with the
shrinking man just like it like i said
in the sense that this is one dude's
experience with something extraordinary
and the murder mystery is almost i don't
want to say incidental
but it's almost kind of like more a
background aspect
of what's happening like him exploring
what's happening to him with this new
ability
the movie like i said probably made the
right decision
in putting the ghost story you know
first and foremost putting it right in
the focus
and having everything else like all the
other things that he sees
you know that takes place all the
visions that he has
tying directly or indirectly into the
central mystery
the book is not so much like that it's
you know so just kind of know that going
into it
but if you like richard matheson if you
like his style
as i said if you don't know who he is
he's written a [ __ ] ton of stuff he
wrote all
probably all the best uh twilight zone
episodes um or
some of the best ones anyway nightmare
at twenty thousand feet probably the
most famous one
that he wrote about the guy on the wing
the plane uh but he's written [ __ ] tons
of stuff and he's a fantastic writer
massive influence on stephen king and
you can really see that if you read some
of his stuff
so as i said this is i don't think it's
his best novel but it's a real good one
and it's really
entertaining like the suspense builds up
and um but just go
into it knowing that it's not if you've
seen the movie it's not exactly like the
movie you know what i mean it's
it's the same outline but it goes in a
different direction and has a different
focus
but i would recommend both because i
think both are really entertaining just
you know for different reasons but yeah
so uh
like i said if you have not read it or
seen the movie
it is stir of echoes is the movie a stir
of echoes is the novel like i said not
like it's a huge
difference but you know there it is
uh so definitely check it out and i will
see you on the next one bye